en algún vídeo anterior argumentó que el
rango de una matriz am es igual al rango
de su transpuesta y fue algo que dije
sin demostrar lo dije como un dogma de
fe porque estaba algo cansada pero lo
voy a retomar porque porque es
importante es un concepto de suma
importancia y nos ayudará a entender lo
ya aprendido así que vamos a iniciar con
esto voy a voy a iniciar primero con el
rango de la trans puesta con esta parte
entonces el rango de la trans puesta de
una matriz es igual a la dimensión del
espacio columna de la matriz transpuesta
de a transpuesta esa es la definición de
rango y la dimensión del espacio columna
de una matriz transpuesta es igual al
número de vectores en la base para el
espacio columna de la trans puesta
entonces para cualquier sub espacio que
tengas averiguas cuantos vectores
necesitas para formar tu base los
cuentas y esa es su dimensión ajá es el
número de vectores en la base para el
espacio columna de 1
transpuesta y donde esto el espacio
columna es lo que conocemos como el
espacio fila de a ajá las columnas de la
trans puesta son lo mismo que las filas
de a sol o simplemente cambias las filas
y columnas ok perfecto ahora bien cómo
podemos como podemos averiguar cuántos
vectores necesitamos para la base de del
espacio columna de a transpuesta o el
espacio fila de a vamos a pensar en esto
vamos a pensar primero en el espacio
columna de a transpuesta lo que voy a
hacer aquí es dibujar a la matriz
de esta manera tenemos a es una matriz
de m por n
voy a poner a la matriz a como un montón
de un montón de vectores columna o filas
de vectores entonces tenemos aquí la
fila 1 la fila 2 sería esta esto es la
fila 2 hasta llegar a la fila m ajá es
una matriz de m por n cada vector es de
en elementos
y tenemos n columnas y esa es la matriz
a ahora para la matriz transpuesta de a
se va a mirar algo así la voy a poner de
esta manera a traspuesta sería esto
tenemos r1 r2 hasta llegar a ere m ajá
ha transpuesto es una matriz de n por m
por lo tanto las filas de a serán las
columnas de a transpuesta y también cabe
mencionar que el espacio columna de a
transpuesta es igual aquí lo voy a poner
el espacio columna de a transpuesta es
igual al generado de r1 r2 hasta rm o
equivalente esto es igual al generado de
las filas de la matriz a de hecho sólo
voy a escribir aquí porque es importante
entonces esto esto es igual al generado
de las filas de la matriz a estos son
conceptos equivalentes y ok ya muy bien
entonces estos son los sub espacios
generados son todas las combinaciones
lineales de las columnas o de estas
filas entonces si queremos las bases
queremos lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar un conjunto mínimo de vectores
linealmente independientes que podamos
usar para construir cualquiera de estas
columnas o cualquiera de estas filas
ahora qué sucede cuando ponemos a la
matriz a en su forma escalonada reducida
lo que queremos hacer es efectuar un
montón de operaciones con las filas para
que esté en su forma escalonada reducida
entonces eventualmente haciendo las
operaciones con las filas obtendrás la
forma escalonada reducida de la matriz a
baja con algunas entradas pivote se
mirarán
algo así la voy a dibujar con algunas
entradas pivotes digamos que esta es una
de ellas
tendríamos aquí puros ceros después acá
tenemos otra entrada pivote y digamos
que ok digamos que las siguientes no son
entonces ésta no es ni esta entrada
pivote después cero si digamos que está
si es una entrada pivote y ahí lo
tenemos entonces algo así se mirará en
esta en esta matriz ya tienes algunas
entradas pivote y las y las obtienes
realizando operaciones en las filas de
la matriz estas operaciones puedes por
ejemplo tú sumar dos veces a la fila 2
le sumas dos veces la fila 1 y ese
entonces será tu fila 2 ahora si sigue
realizando operaciones obtienes la forma
escalonada reducida así que estas filas
son combinaciones lineales de estas
otras filas y otra manera sería por
ejemplo revertir estas operaciones
entonces digamos que aquí yo hago
operaciones con filas lo voy a escribir
otra vez hago operaciones con filas para
obtener la matriz a voy como en reverso
otra manera de pensar en esto
los vectores ellos generan a todos estos
es decir todos estos vectores pueden ser
representados como combinaciones
lineales de las filas pivote obviamente
sus filas no tus filas que no sean
pivote serán compuestos por puros ceros
pero esos son irrelevantes
ajá no no importan pero tus filas
pivotes y tomas combinaciones lineales
de ellos puedes revertir las operaciones
y regresar a tu matriz original así que
todos estos pueden ser representados
como combinaciones lineales de estos y
todos todos todas las entradas pivotes
son por definición bueno de hecho casi
por definición no exactamente son
linealmente independientes porque ve
aquí yo tengo un 1 y ningún otro
elemento de la columna es 1 así que no
puede ser presentado como combinación
lineal de los otros ahora bien por qué
es importante esto porque recuerda que
iniciamos diciendo que queríamos
encontrar una base para el espacio fila
cierto creamos un conjunto mínimo de
vectores linealmente independientes que
generen ahora bien todos estos pueden
ser representados como combinación
lineal de estos vectores en las filas de
estos vectores pivote
y ya está esto en la forma escalonada
reducida y todos son linealmente
independientes entonces forman una base
razonable así que éstas son filas pivote
aquí tenemos una acá tenemos otra aquí
tendríamos la tercera y bueno tal vez
haya más pero en este ejemplo es muy
particular así que esto sería una base
razonable para el espacio fila lo voy a
escribir aquí entonces las filas pivote
en la en la forma escalonada reducida
las filas pivote en la forma escalonada
reducida de la matriz a son una base
para el espacio fila de a
y el espacio fila de am es lo mismo que
el espacio de columna de a transpuesta
entonces también lo pongo aquí
pongo o el espacio columna de a
transpuesta el espacio fila de a es lo
mismo que el espacio columna de a
transpuesta ahora si queremos conocer la
dimensión del espacio columna
simplemente contamos contamos el número
de filas pivote que tenemos entonces la
dimensión de la de tu espacio fila lo
cual es lo mismo que que el espacio
columna de a transpuesta será el número
de filas pivote en la forma escalonada
reducida o hecho más sencillo es el
número de entradas pivote que tienes ajá
porque cada cada entrada pivote tiene
una fila pivote podemos decir entonces
que el rango de a transpuesta es igual
al número de entradas pivote en la forma
escalonada reducida de la matriz y en la
forma escalonada reducida de a porque
cada entrada tivo te corresponde a una
fila pivote estas filas pivote forman
una base para el espacio fila cada fila
es combinación lineal de estos ajá
entonces así que lo que éstos generan
éstos generan
y ahora cuál es el rango de a cuál es el
rango de la matriz a encontramos el
rango de la matriz a transpuesta baja
pero y el rango de a cuál es el rango de
a lo voy a escribir aquí entonces el
rango de a es igual es igual a la
dimensión del espacio columna de a a a-
o lo que es lo mismo también es el el
número de vectores en la base para el
espacio columna de a cierto entonces si
tomamos a la matriz a y en lugar de
vectores fila ponemos vectores columna
de esta forma entonces tenemos asm por n
y voy a poner en lugar de filas pongo
columnas tenemos la columna 1 la columna
2 hasta la columna n tenemos n columnas
ahora el espacio de columna es
esencialmente el sub espacio generado
por estos elementos a por cada uno de
estos vectores columna entonces el
espacio columna de amd es igual al
generador de c1 c2 hasta cn esa es la
definición pero queremos saber
de vectores en la base es cierto el
número de vectores en la base
una base razonable sí sí esto sí esto lo
convierte es a su forma escalonada
reducida entonces tienes algunos algunas
entradas pivote y su columna pivote
correspondiente entonces tendrías por
ejemplo así algunas entradas pivote
algunas no y así se miraría esto
entonces tiene cierta cantidad de
columnas pivote voy a usar otro color
para esto cuando por operaciones llegas
a la forma escalonada reducida de la
matriz a aprendimos que los vectores en
la base los que forman una base para tu
espacio columna son las columnas que
corresponden a las columnas pivot es
cierto a estas columnas entonces esta es
una columna pivote por lo tanto este
puede ser un vector de la base y lo que
quieres hacer es contar el número de
vectores que hay en la base porque date
cuenta que no no necesitas saber quiénes
son esos vectores de la base sino saber
la cantidad de vectores que hay en la
base y observa que para cada para cada
columna pivote aquí tenemos un vector
base que le corresponde entonces
solamente contamos las columnas pivote y
el número de columnas pivote con
responde al número de entradas pivote
que tenemos por lo tanto podemos decir
que el rango de a lo escribo el rango de
a es igual es igual al número de
entradas pivote en la forma escalonada
reducida de la matriz an en la forma
escalonada reducida de la matriz amp y
como puedes ver es exactamente lo mismo
para el rango de la trans puesta es
cierto es decir la dimensión del espacio
columna de a transpuesta o lo que es lo
mismo la dimensión del espacio fila de a
y con esto ya hemos llegado a nuestra
conclusión lo que queríamos demostrar
era que el rango de an es igual al rango
de la trans puesta en efecto que son
iguales bueno nos vemos pronto